this is a production of cornell
university
okay
so um
don't hold it against me having got my
phd from dartmouth i i guess an ivy
rival but i did actually my first
acceptance for my chemistry degree was
from cornell and i had to actually sit
there and think about it um i couldn't
have lost either way
um thank you so much this is such a
treat to be able to share
the story of where we've gotten to to
date with this project and really you
can think about this talk in several
different dimensions
you can
focus on the interesting genetics that
we uncovered because really
we're just a bunch of gregor mendel
instead of playing with peas
um
we're just playing with with tomatoes
because none of us are professional
horticulturist we just have curiosity
or you can think about the concept of
how we ran this project because
we started this back in 2005 and really
did use a citizen science approach which
is why when my book is finally done i
will actually title it the word that i
invented crowd breeding because we used
a crowd of people to breed tomatoes
or you can focus as i discussed the
project down what are some of the risks
and the challenges that we encountered
along the way
so i always like to start people off by
sharing what my own garden is like here
in hendersonville and
we did garden and live in raleigh for 28
years and it was really hot and really
humid and getting really crowded
so we moved to andersonville which is
any of you who know where asheville is
it's about 20 miles south so trader
joe's is not too far away
my backyard is a septic field so i have
to grow on top so all of my garden is
planted in containers or straw bales and
the results are excellent however this
is what it looked like as of yesterday
our season
is extremely compressed here in
hendersonville
because diseases really start becoming
very present and aggressive in
mid-august and beyond
so typically
my entire crop comes in between the
first week of july
and the middle of august
what you see here is healthy plants on
the on the left end are eggplant and
peppers which handle the issues in our
climate here much better than the
tomatoes did but it was a great season
so why did we decide to tackle this
project anyway
i really caught the heirloom tomato bug
in the mid 80s
and when we moved to raleigh and went to
the farmers market we realized
no one there was really carrying
anything interesting tomato wise in
terms of starts except for things like
german johnson
so we started selling seedlings there
right around 1998
and the most frequent question that
people were asking me is i love the
concept of heirlooms all of the colors
all of the flavors but i don't want to
climb a ladder to pick my tomato
i have to grow it on a deck or a patio
or a driveway so what have you got
in terms of plants that i can grow in a
five gallon pot and they taste great and
the answer at the time
was not a whole heck of a lot
um there are determinate varieties of
course the color range was pretty
limited but you had yellow taxi and you
had the red roma types
but the flavor and the diversity of
morphology just wasn't there
and the other major phenotype of
tomatoes
in terms of their growth habit the
dwarfs
were quite obscure and not many people
even knew about them and in fact
these were the five that were available
uh commonly available when we started
our project and most of them are from
the 1800s like dwarf champion golden
dwarf champion new big dwarf and dwarf
stone were from the early 1900s
tom wagner created a really nice tomato
with lime green salad but never took it
any further than that and that was from
the mid 70s
i like to collect seed catalog so in a
way i'm a bit of a tomato historian and
genealogist and
when i opened the page of the 1915
isbell catalog and saw this depiction
new big dwarf ponderosa size fruits on
dwarf champion vines that means one
pound tomatoes on three to four feet
tall plants and they described what they
did they crossed ponderosa a dwarf
champion created the hybrid and then i
assumed they spent four or five years
picking through the f2 and beyond to get
this particular combination
so i met my friend online katrina in
australia who loved to do tomato crosses
and i had ideas for we wanted to cross
and we set upon this project
petrina actually came over to the us in
2000 2009 or 10
to attend our tomato palooza event
where we gathered all of my tomato plant
customers together and we would
typically have 250 varieties 250 people
we'd all get canker sores
ingest lots of mallocs because of all
the acidity
but petrina and i here are shown meaning
the dwarf tomato project table
the early generation finds that we were
coming out with
and in a way
this is
the punch line of the talk
because this describes where we have
been and where we are and then the rest
of talk is describing how this all
worked but
we formed this project in 2005 through a
discussion and here we are in 2022
we started ratcheting it down a little
bit in 2018 because it was getting out
of control but in that span of 17 years
and counting
we have enlisted the talents of a
thousand or more volunteers from all
over the world
in 50 states
in 25 different countries and we have
placed
145 stable open pollinated varieties in
various seed catalogs and that has been
uh really exciting now
the the australian u.s split happened
maybe around 2014 2015 when seed import
laws became really onerous and petrina
and i could no longer share seeds back
and forth
so she is doing her thing
in australia and i'm still doing my
thing with lots of people in the country
so here are the key project attributes
it's all amateur all volunteer
uh the project leads either petrina or
myself or maybe a few other people that
like to do crosses
would make the crosses between an
indeterminate and a dwarf variety
the project leads would grow the hybrids
and then we would collect lots of f2
seed and distribute it around
we would make the decisions based on the
findings in terms of what is a good lead
and what is not one of the things that
our volunteers really like is if they
find it they get to name it and we have
tomatoes named for cats and dogs and
flowers and birds and aunts and uncles
and and you name it
the new varieties the new named
varieties are released only when they
are stable open pollinated varieties so
what we didn't want to do it's put a lot
of early generation material out to the
public which would then end up in seed
libraries or the seed savers exchange
with no name attached and no ability to
replicate the results
the profits
are for the real the releasing seed
companies so one of the things we
decided let's pick some seed companies
that need something to help them become
visible
and we will essentially just have
a quantity of seeds grown out by one of
our volunteers give them the seeds it
could be 2 000 seeds or 5 000 seeds
the company would germ test it package
it up look at our description put a link
to our website on their website
and that is how we got all of our
varieties out there so it's the seed
companies that get to gain something
from this
i told all of our volunteers right off
the bat
this project's going to be a lot of fun
but the pay is terrible as in zero
um
but that's fine because we wanted to do
something for space challenge gardeners
as you heard in the and at the beginning
and all varieties we pledged to the open
source seed initiative because what we
wanted is when people grow our varieties
we didn't want to put any
limitations on their use for further
breeding so we've essentially just given
these seeds to the gardening public or
plant dream public to do what they wish
and when we get to the page at the end
where i look at risks and challenges
we'll talk a little bit more about that
so um very briefly how do we do this we
i bought a veggie bee
and it comes with a shiny black spoon
and some tweezers
and
we at the beginning decided the best way
to get early clarity of our success in
the crosses is to remove pollen from the
indeterminate variety that's the male
and then
we would
uh pull the anther cone just before it's
fully open and before itself pollinates
from the dwarf variety
this really helps in terms of knowing if
our project
took right away and i'll talk about that
in a moment
we
dip
the pistol the style from the pistol
into and forgive me if my genetic turns
become a little bit garbled
like i said i do this for the love of it
and for the history and the stories and
the flavors
i need to brush up on my specific
genetic terms i'm sure but you just dip
into the pollen and
i like to uh cut the sepals a little bit
to
as a fallback but i always put a twisty
tie
when i make the cross and then if the if
the ovary swells
you hope that you got in there and did
the pollen before it's self-pollinated
and i put a little x on it
this is petrina in australia in her
dwarf
r d garden where she's growing
lots of varieties close together to pack
in as much as possible
we don't worry a whole lot about
crossing because the bees have proven
not to spend a lot of time low down in
these plants
and we focus off the first set fruit on
the plants anyway because a lot of times
when these plants blossom the bees
aren't around and so and it's a breeding
project so undoubtedly we're getting a
little bit of crossing but we're looking
at growing things out to f7 or fsa eight
so we're not worried too much about that
these are some examples of in raleigh of
my setups for the year and they look
nice and neat early on but what happens
is these plants grow to three or four
feet tall and they get heavy with fruit
and you end up with a pickups uh pickup
stick situation after a while
but you can again get a lot of r d done
in a small amount of space
and this is what my
driveway and raleigh used to look like
the reason i grow everything in my
driveway driveways because that's where
the sun shone and the place where i did
have my hand dug garden the trees grew
to the point where the plants weren't
getting the hours of direct sun they
needed to be productive so it all went
into my driveway
i retired
i was lucky to retire from big pharma
early enough
to call this my office
when i when i'm still young enough now
to be able to get around and attend all
this stuff but it's been a lot of fun
hendersonville is much more rural
and it's just a different setup
altogether but i still have places where
the sun shines
and i put up pallets and this area on
the gravel driveway is where i do a lot
of the comparative growing and the
growing out for the dwarf project
so a little bit more about dwarfs
the gene that causes the dwarf growth
also
seems to be linked to another
manifestation which is is crinkling up
the foliage and making it a very dark
bluish green which is actually very
attractive
the early seed catalogs
called this rugose r-u-g-o-s-e
and in fact the very first dwarf showed
up in a sea catalog in 1850
called tomato de lei d e capital l-a-y-e
and it was a mutation that occurred in a
different variety in a in a castle
garden in france
so from that
i think came pretty much everything else
but
on the left is a regular leaf dwarf on
the top and foliage from a regular leaf
determinate or indeterminate on the
bottom and you can see how
the foliage gets crinkled up and there
are potato leaf dwarfs on the right the
dwarf version of potato leaf is on the
top and the indeterminate version is on
the bottom
why we really like playing with the
duaras
so these are the three main types of
plant habit there of course is another
one called micro dwarf which are
extremely short and we that's out of
scope for us but indeterminants as we
all know take over the garden
this is me standing nick
hello
this is me standing next to cherokee
purple in july it's already eight feet
tall i'm six feet tall where's it gonna
go from there
determinate plants in on the uh top
right
form essentially a ball of tomatoes that
all wrote ripen in a quite concentric
time
and that's fine if you're a canner but
there is
my view and i've talked to rob johnson
at johnny's about this
the level of fruit versus foliage is
almost so out of whack because they're
so heavy yielding that they never seem
to develop the truly intense flavors as
indeterminants for dwarfs i think of
dwarfs
as a subtype that grow at half the
vertical rate of indeterminants but
fruit throughout the season until killed
by frost
so if your cherokee purple grows 10 feet
tall your corresponding dwarf will reach
4 feet tall and i've actually measured
the growth of tomatoes and i've found
that indeterminates when they really get
kicking in are growing two to three
inches a day
and dwarfs are growing about an inch a
day so there's that half
and they're beautiful plants these are
three dwarfs sitting in five gallon
containers there is the potato leaf
dwarf and the right front and a regular
leaf dwarf and the left front
so
dominant traits and tomatoes that we
learn just enough some of this by trial
and error some of it of course by
reading
indeterminate is
dominant to dwarf or determinant regular
relief shape the serrated edges is
dominant to potato leaf
yellow skin color is dominant to clear
skin
red flesh color is dominant to yellow
i put orange there but there seems to be
a bit more complexity with orange
dominance we had some surprises but
clearly red flesh color is dominant to
green or white
small fruit size is dominant which has
really affected our work on some of our
dwarf families
round is dominant unless a heart is
involved in which case that partially
comes through in some of the work we've
done
and stripes and anthocyanins also
partially come through so it's been a
fun drive
we use the dwarf as the female because
the fruit grows on the dwarf plant but
you can then ripen a fruit that fruit
that you cross and it do a test
germination that same year
and if your plants are indeterminate you
know the crossword because indeterminate
is dominant
when you save those seeds
you grow out the hybrid and then you
save seeds from it and this is what we
pass around and send our volunteers on
dwarf hunting expeditions
because in the f2 75 percent of ceilings
are indeterminate 25 or dwarf and i'll
show you a picture that's really easy to
spot even early on
if a potato leaf was apparent
25 percent of those 25 percent will be
potato leaves so now as you start
working in determinant traits so
variegated foliage potato leaf clear
skin yellow flesh it becomes harder to
find the combinations you want but once
you've got them you've got them
dwarf seedlings are very distinctive
they're half the height of the
indeterminants they have a thicker stem
however it can take six to ten
generations to stabilize one of our new
varieties the reason that working with
australia was so great and we use
florida in the same way because they can
get extra seasons in is we could bat it
back and forth and we could get to an f8
generation in four years um you can
assume that none of us volunteers or a
few of us had greenhouses or things like
that so most of us are one season
growers
you can see here this is a mix of types
the indeterminants are look at the
cells front and back at the extreme
right the indeterminants are in the back
the dwarfs are in the front we've also
noticed that the cotyledons on the
dwarfs tend to be a bit more rounded
whereas the ones in indeterminants are a
bit more elongated
and here you've got probably brandywine
one of my favorite varieties on the left
an indeterminate potato leaf variety and
one of our new dwarfs on the right
showing that half height thing
another view
and the dwarfs even show
the different foliage type it's starting
to show they're twinkling on the right
the one in the center is a determinant i
believe this is taxi and the foliage of
determinants looks pretty much the same
as indeterminants
we achieve diversity quite quick so when
you do a project you look for the proof
of concept
can we cross indeterminants with dwarfs
and find interesting dwarf varieties
that show attributes of the
indeterminates that were used absolutely
this is only from about 2007 or 2008 and
every tomato on this table is from the
dwarf tomato breeding projects many of
which were exceeding a pound and when
you start seeing a plant loaded up with
16 to 20 ounce fruit a three foot plant
you do have to give it some support
emotional
as well as physical
an example of some of the colors
that we're playing with here
this is one of our crosses
of cherokee chocolate on the left which
is one of my favorite indeterminates we
crossed it with dwarf mr snow on the
right one of my favorite dwarfs it's one
of our ivory colored or white dwarfs the
f1 hybrid in the middle this represents
the chalky family we'll get about naming
in a second
so the red flesh of cherokee chocolate
combined with the yellow skin of
cherokee chocolate created a scarlet red
tomato so dwarf mr snow had clear skin
and white flesh both recessive genes
that did not express and the hybrid this
is just a slight offshoot i've really
taken to
making crosses between my favorite
indeterminate variety heirloom varieties
to see what happens with the flavor can
i create even better tomatoes
so two of my top three tomatoes are
cherokee purple on the left lillian's
yellow heirloom on the right and i made
a hybrid the hybrid is in the middle is
one of the best tomatoes i've ever eaten
in my entire life and i'm actually
playing around with the f2 generation
this year just to see what i get
the ways that we learned about the
partial dominance of heart and stripes
this is a striped indeterminate on the
left dunn's double delight and a
heart-shaped indeterminate kanselmo
family heirloom on the right the hybrid
is on the bottom it is faintly striped
and slightly heart-shaped so pretty
interesting stuff
so when you do a project like this and
we're developing dwarf tomatoes katrina
thought of the disney movie
um and so we had names for the families
of our first set of dwarfs sneezy sleepy
grumpy happy bashful
dopey duck however um that's not enough
names and we now have 100 families when
we create when we cross an indeterminate
with a dwarf
we call that hybrid the beginning of a
family and then all of the work from
that cross is under the family name and
so already you see one of our california
crossers with a sense of humor named his
cross sleazy
and petrina named one witty
we've gone all over the map with our
families but these are the first ones
and you can see the component varieties
most of these are
existing dwarfs golden dwarf champion
buddha torp which comes from europe
we didn't have our own dwarfs to use as
crossing partners
so we hoped that and and none of these
are outstanding varieties to eat
so we hope that by crossing those known
dwarfs with outstanding varieties like
green giant stump of the world and
carbon and cherokee chocolate
we would get expressions of the
excellence of flavor in some of our f2s
this is for example how we created
summertime green which is one of my
favorite dwarfs it is a regular leaf
dwarf plant four feet tall that produces
16 ounce green tomatoes that are off the
chart flavor-wise and that originated
from a cross between golden dwarf
champion
and green giant and that we call that
the sneezy family and we have ten
releases just from that family they're
all either green or yellow or white
they're either potato leaf or regular
leaf and they are all just outstanding
so this is one of our first learning is
that the intense flavor genes of green
giant seem to completely overwhelm
the average at best flavored genes of
golden dwarf champion and show up in
almost all of our releases
another thing we learned is to not
expect much from your f1 hybrid
so
if you cross a great tomato with these
dwarfs should your hybrids taste great
as we found not really in fact
you can see these in the in the top is
sneezy and sleepy and witty working to
the right they're all
medium-sized even less than medium-sized
red tomatoes with the exception of a few
and the only ones that tasted really
really good were sneezy in the upper
left and sleazy in the lower right in
fact sleazy was such a delicious tomato
this was new big dwarf times carbon the
tomatoes were uniform o blade
one pound pink tomatoes with just an
outstanding flavor
so we haven't gone back to do this but
some of these hybrids we created people
would buy these as hybrids because
they're so delicious
however it was in the growing out of the
f-2s that we found the treasures so just
to take you on a little bit of a
travelogue through some of our favorites
to show
just some of the diversity and some of
the potential of this project
dwarf sweet sue came out of the sneezy
family it's an eight ounce bright yellow
sometimes a little pink blush my wife's
name is sue it's one of my favorite
dwarfs so that worked out well for me
and her
speckled heart
in the upper right we use speckled roman
in that to to bring the stripes into the
fruit
and that is an eight ounce beautiful
solid heart
that has much greater use beyond just
sauce because it is really delicious tea
and it's really really prolific
fred's tie dye in the lower left is
essentially what it looks like if you
take a cherokee purple and some green or
gold paint and you paint tie-dye stripes
on it
absolutely outstanding and one of brad
gates uh wild boar i think pink berkeley
tie-dye may have been used to introduce
the stripes into this crossing with
dwarf wild fred one of our purple dwarfs
and then we even discovered some colors
we didn't know existed the black orange
the orange tomato that with that with
whole some of the chlorophyll so with
cherokee chocolate and cherokee purple
you have pink or red tomatoes that
retain chlorophyll which gives them a
purple or a brownish cast uluru ochre is
an orange tomato that retains some of
that chlorophyll because cherokee purple
was used in creating this cross with the
orange tomato elb and it the flavor of
uluru ochre is absolutely outstanding 12
to 14 ounce beautiful tomatoes
one of my favorite colored ones this is
from the beauty family
and this used berkeley tie-dye
with
one of our dwarfs whose name escapes me
but we ended up with seven releases
we've got chocolate with green stripes
and this is pink with gold stripes
red with gold stripes yellow with pink
stripes
green with pink stripes
the problem with this beauty family is
it's been really tough to absolutely
nail down the colors so we'll think we
have it stable and we'll grow it a bunch
and what we have a rogue plant in there
but it's been fun to work with and
they're really delicious
we've taken to look in a little bit of
paste tomatoes so tiger eye
is an orange paste that has that
chlorophyll retention
and purple heartthrob
is a just a wild colored tomato that's
heart shaped about eight ounces long
deep deep crimson flesh absolutely
wonderful flavor
now we found that when we cross mexico
[ __ ] which is the tiniest of tomatoes
i it's a pimpin pimping folium for sure
it's the size of a pea
we cross that with summertime green
which i showed you the one pound green
the hybrid was just a normal cherry
tomato
so that tiny
genetics of mexico [ __ ] played really
strongly into the hybrid
and the f2 as unlocking we have these in
purple and pink white yellow green
orange
so apparently there's just a great
amount of genetic diversity i actually
think mexico [ __ ] may be closely
related to the wild ancestral tomato
from
the west coast of south america
it was found growing wild by someone
in the texas mexico border and given to
someone in california
barney layman by his brother and barney
sent it to me and mexico midget's one of
the most popular tomatoes i grow but we
now really have released a delicious
yellow dwarf tomato cherry tomato eagle
smiley on the right whose flavor
actually approaches sun gold people
really love it
we've used the tomato variegated to
breed variegation into a lot of our
varieties and we're starting to release
some of those this is dwarf walters
fancy named after my grandfather walter
the fruit is ivory colored
and
we've used a little bit of anthocyanin
in some of our varieties this is one of
tom wagner's anthocyanin cherries that
was given to a friend and she sent it to
me and i bred it
with an indeterminate and we started
down the road of creating some of these
my problem with the anthocyanin dwarfs
to date and in fact almost all
anthocyanin varieties that i've tasted
is i'm finding the flavor either unusual
or a little bit lacking so our project
has yet to produce an anthocyanin
shoulder tomato that we actually love
this year is an example because i grew
most of my dwarf work this year was
using a variety called dwarf mocha's
plum
which is a little two ounce um purple
plum with a heavy anther shoulder and i
crossed them with some of my favorite
indeterminates like don's double delight
lillian's yellow heirloom lucky cross
this is the result i grew up maybe
eight f twos they're really pretty i've
got brown plums and bicolored hearts and
purple with antho round and plum
none of them have the flavor i'm looking
for so
in a project like this you also have to
be willing to call it a dead end and i
ran into some dead ends um i actually
have some show-and-tells
this is dwarf strawberry lemonade this
is one of our recent dwarf releases
it's pink smooth this one's about eight
ounces absolutely delicious
and this is dwarf snake bite
these can go to 16 ounces they've got a
little bit of green shoulder a little
corrugation
but really a nice form and
very much
we have created uh yes
are you showing new slides are you
you're mentioning new varieties or are
you actually holding a tomato oh oh you
know what i'm doing i can see myself
showing them but what i'm going to do is
when we get to the end and the slides
are done i will do the show and tell so
thanks for that this is this is the
first time i've tried show and tell in
one of these so forgive me for a tech
glitch um we'll move on
a project like this you have to document
and there is a website called
tomatoville which is set up as a p2p
and the owner of craig allowed us to
manage our project in here so we created
subcategories for all of our families
we under each family would we could
create discussion threads for all of our
leads
and in those threads we could put
pictures so this gave katrina and i a
bird's eye view into everything people
are doing the risk in that
is the owner of tomatoville is not sure
he wants to keep tomatoville up
and at this point he doesn't seem to be
willing to have us extract all of our
information so this is a conundrum that
we're dealing with
and even when we have a variety released
we would list
the entire genealogy of that variety who
who grew it
what the vial number was because i keep
really
really really disciplined notes on all
of this
here in excel
so everything is cross-referenced by
number into an excel spreadsheet with
the name of the variety the family it
comes from the person who sent me the
seed the source file that they grew it
from and then a full description
there is a company that is decided to
focus on these and
sell all of our varieties so
dwarf
victory seeds right from the start has
wanted to partner with us
they introduced a lot of them and now
pretty much they're introducing all of
our new releases and they have a
separate page set up
where you can go and uh look at
descriptions and all
so now this is kind of um
there's a few slides you want to get
into that are a little more wordy than i
like but they they get into the nub of
this project
how do we promote these word of mouth
primarily was our publicity method it
was very much bottom up rather than top
down we just want to put stuff out there
and see what people thought of it uh
victory southern exposure sandhill
heritage and a few others were part of
our initial releases uh fruition is in
there some really good smaller companies
um
so our first release releases were in
2010
and the other day i went and started
googling names of our varieties for
example tasmanian chocolate
20 seed catalogs and i didn't even do an
exhaustive search so this bottom-up
approach has worked it's kind of if you
build it they will come
um 2011 our release sweet sue is listed
in a whole bunch of catalogs so they are
getting around just fine
through word of mouth and it's really up
to the seed companies that offer these
to decide and instagram and facebook i'm
sure have become really effective tools
this is the slide we need to talk about
the needs of the project the risks and
the challenges i in my old job at glaxo
i was a chemist but i also became a
project manager and
i i became keenly aware of how important
data management is
project organization follow-through
discipline
stamina all of those things that a lot
of us lack
resources are critical especially
consistent resources so if we've used a
thousand people all over the world i
could probably pick out the 25 to 30
that were the core volunteers that
carried out 70 to 80 of the work
adequate and consistent data collection
people will think something's a good
idea in spring but then when their big
garden starts harvesting are they taking
all the pictures are they weighing are
they saving seeds
uh the collaborative working tool
tomatoville came around at the right
time and was structured beautifully for
our needs but its future existence is
tenuous
the consistent return of seed samples
you end up doing a lot of hounding and
because we spread this project so big
and wide and we're not doing it for the
money not getting a seed back being
delayed on a line was not a tragedy but
still that is an issue the barriers to
seed sharing between
us and anywhere is the way it's starting
to turn out and it's understandable
because places don't want
for
diseases that can adhere to or embed
themselves in the seed coats of tomatoes
to to be released in other areas where
it's not existent
here's the big bugaboo for me we we've
left so much on the cutting room floor
because of we are all limited by the
size of the gardens
in which we could carry out our projects
so sufficient space populations to
explore all the popul the not only the
possibilities but how stable our
releases were when we sent them to the
company
and here's two more learning about our
releases i get so many emails saying
i'm gardening in vermont pick me out
three dwarfs that will really do well
for me or
i'm in arizona um could you name me an
orange or a green dwarf that will do
well for me
we don't know yet we've released these
to the world all of our children are out
there we don't know how they behave we
don't know
and look at this last one initial focus
of this project
was on color and size or flavor the
morphological diversity the things we
could see and touched and taste
we don't know
what the various disease tolerances or
susceptibilities are for these and at
best they're anecdotal where i've grown
a bunch of them out
hey summertime green really seemed to go
down to disease was it just that season
so there is potential future work people
can take these and try if they love them
they can breathe disease tolerance and
resistance into them
um i'm going to do show and tell in a
second and take questions
petrina has a dwarf tomato project
website up i'm going to show links in a
moment
these are my two books anybody who's
interested in them can
can email me and we can work that out
i am here doing this i'm gardening
because my grandfather and dad embedded
the love of gardening for me so all of
you
grow a gardener grow your gardens but
find other people we this i think
gardening is going to save the world so
we have to do this
this is uh my website i can send this
you can have it distributed if it's my
website my email
until last thursday i was in my driveway
doing instagram lives every for 45
minutes every thursday just to take
questions and take people on tours of my
garden
and petrina's website and between his
email
and take a picture of the screen if you
want
um i asked katrina
so this is a collaborative list of what
our favorite dwarf tomatoes are and the
ones that are bolded this just flavor
the ones that are bolded we both love
and then the ones that i have my name
after i particularly love and the ones
that her name is after she particularly
loves
you know i kind of go through this i'm
not sure how we're doing on time but it
was it's always a great joy for me to
share what we've done and i just hope
that all of you found something just a
little bit interesting i sparked an idea
you know something that you may want to
get in touch with me about that i can
help you with to take this in a
different direction but it's i'm not
stopping guarding anytime soon uh my
sabbatical that i'm taking from social
networking largely is to finish writing
the book
on the dwarf tomato project at this
point i'm going to think i'm thinking of
self-publishing it but i'm in
discussions with
a few other organizations to see if they
want to collaborate on it and give me a
hand on that but
that's kind of what i have to say and
thanks for your attention
thank you great yeah nice talk and oh
and and here we go
so this is
snake bite
and you can see where it this is 10
ounces it's a smooth pink it has got a
lot of the attributes of heirlooms and
being uh
green up i got to remember i'm going
backwards to my camera green shouldered
and this is the beautiful variety dwarf
strawberry lemonade
almost has the flavor of a brandywine
really super productive so you get your
eight to ten ounce slicing tomatoes on a
four foot tall plant and those are grown
by my friend adam and i got them during
a beer yesterday we met at a local pub
and he brought them to me and i figured
i could use them today so there you go
yeah so very nice i mean so much uh
genetic variation and so many unknowns
maybe you can collaborate with cornell
research right in the future and
actually
right okay so
yeah go ahead i met i actually met mike
at um
the organic seed meeting in corvallis
two years ago i think mike i forget his
name begins with him might
meditate yeah um and he and i talked a
little bit about it um
my view is we've done the project i talk
about it and then if things are supposed
to happen
it'll happen so i don't worry about that
and if people do see potential in these
i think they're exciting varieties a lot
of my
seedling customers went all to dwarfs
because they just got sick of tying up
10 foot tall indeterminants and
this has really been a big help to
people who just want to grow a nice
plant on their deck
so any question from the audience
yeah okay
uh so your question is how to identify
the warranty
okay so the question is
uh how do you find so many volunteers in
the project
any
what was the word
right i mean is that your question yeah
how are you finding some volunteers yes
um sorry um
so
god i could talk a half hour just about
this part
there are gardeners out there who are
dying
to make their gardens more interesting
so
if you're on a website like um
tomatoville or
if you're on
you know if you're on twitter if you're
on instagram if you're on facebook
and you talk about your work and you put
out
and
you kind of tease people a little bit
with the saying hum you know you sh
clearly you're showing how much fun it
is because you're so excited about the
project
but then you get people start saying
i would love to help you out with that
and you know i'll say well just send me
an email we'll work things out and just
from the instagram lives that i've done
this in last year each time i get to the
end of the season i've got 20 or 30 more
people that i'm sending seeds off to so
you get volunteers by
not making it intimidating not putting a
lot of rules in front of people
making it feel like they can do it if
they can grow a tomato plant from seed
then they can
grow it to maturity and save some seeds
from it and send you a picture and
describe it
and then the other
carrot
is
if you find something great your name
will stick with that
the name will stick with that and when
that tomato ends up in a seed catalog
your name is there so we ask anybody who
reduces these who
releases these varieties to include the
entire history so i mean it sounds kind
of corny but it's something to tell your
kids or grandkids someday
i took you know you really like this
tomato we're growing in the yard well i
helped read that so
i think there's lots of different ways
to entice people
i think we're living in a time where
people are looking for interesting fun
things to do to engage them that's
positive
and helping in a breeding project you
don't really have to twist too many
people's arms to dip their toes in the
water
okay yeah so there's one question from
the zoom
for gina so she asked can you talk about
the influences for your
job reading matters that's the first
question
right the second question to what
accident do you take the inspiration
from the participatory planned breeding
matters
um so the first
is around inferences of
a project meaning where does this sit in
i guess it would be where does well
where does our project sit more but more
the type of project the way we set it up
i think that
using um volunteers that are not trained
geneticists and horticulturalists but
avid gardeners to take part in a project
like this
increase scientific knowledge and
engagement
i think that in a time where we're in
such a polarized environment
being able to meet
and uh in the common ground of a common
goal or gardening
and
i think the way that i've seen this
is since my book came out since you're
working on the project i've given a lot
of talks in a lot of places physically
and or resume
and
the question of politics
has never arisen once
and um i mean i clearly have my views
what i've decided to do is there's so
much of it out there
let's keep the gardening and playing
with plants and developing variety space
as
rid of that as possible now i know once
you escape that little bubble you get
into things like patents and profits and
and conglomerates and and things like
that
but i don't just in the same way that
i don't like to get my tux to go too
down the rat holes of what do you spray
your plants with or you know what do you
do you think climate change is a hoax or
not i try to eliminate all that and just
portray myself
using my own values
and all people need to do is listen to
my inter instagram lives and they can
get a pretty good sense of where i stand
and all sorts of things but
but so far as far as i can tell i
haven't alienated anyone and i'm just
trying to grow the pool of gardeners
that want to do this sort of thing um
the second part of the talk i didn't
quite get exactly what you're going for
so could that be repeated the second
part of the question
i i can just uh i can ask my question
out loud today sure hi virginia hi hi
thank you for your talk it's great oh
thank you seems like a super fun project
i was just curious that you know
i'm teaching uh one of the plant
breeding classes and we'll talk a little
bit a little bit about participatory
plant breeding methods and i was
wondering
um yeah like if there were you know
other breeders using participatory
methods that you took inspiration from
when you were developing
well so here's my answer to that i'm one
of these
i i really am kind of gregor mendel type
so even though you know i have my phd in
chemistry and all that and i understand
science
i am thrilled by the process of
discovery so when we set upon this
project
rather than read a lot of genetics books
you know i have barbara lytle's you know
big
big book barbara's a friend of mine and
i take out the magnifying every now and
last every now and then and try to look
at her diagram of all the genes and
where they sit and which chromosomes
but i wanted to set upon a project with
a totally fresh approach
and no preconceptions of what anyone
before us has done or even if they've
done it so i'm very much a um
an explorer and a discoverer and
am
driven by kind of curiosity and
discovery i would say so
growing our f2s and looking at the color
range
and getting excited about what i'm
seeing
and then getting excited about what
they're tasting
um
was great and so in a way i positioned
this project
you know once i write the book people
can look at our results and they'll be
able to infer from that
but it really this really truly was
citizen science of me unplugging myself
now i did use you know when you so when
you get a degree
you follow particular scientific methods
writing up experiments having a
hypothesis using controls
so i have no doubts that i used my
disciplines learning in getting the
degree
not only in doing the project but i ca
you know as people have said i garden
like a scientist so you can't help that
but as much as you can compartmentalize
into that you know turn that side of
your brain off while you're
appreciating just the wonders of growing
and tasting things if you can bring
those two together i think you get a
powerful combination so as you found
with me you can ask a very simple
question and get a bit of an extended
answer but um i'm still excited about
all this i've been gardening for 40
years and i'm just excited about gardens
now as i was 40 years ago so
any of you folks there use me as a
resource to ask anything anytime about
how we set this up where the problems
lie you know anything i can do to help
yeah yeah so that's one more question
okay good
thank you
i was intrigued by your straw bale
gardening angle as well having done that
myself for a couple years now and yeah
the tomatoes and the eggplants and the
peppers seem to be the happiest in that
meal yeah but i was wondering if you see
any g by e are there any interactions
where certain varieties do better on the
bales as opposed to in soil or vice
versa
what a fantastic question and this gets
to
um
this you know so i've i've done this
collaborative tomato course with joe
lampa where he he really is more of the
the general gardening geek and i'm just
the tomato geek but we get a lot of
questions about
how much does how you grow a tomato
affect not only its performance but its
flavor and so i have the
i've been growing certain heirlooms for
many many years so for example cherokee
purple i've grown in six different
places since 1990 um jd green sent it to
me in 1990 and it's been in my garden
ever since many others that i really
love
and i've found whether i'm growing in a
straw bale or a container
or a raised bed or a garden
whether i'm growing them in the three
different locations in pennsylvania or
my two different locations
in north carolina
a great tomato has always ended up being
a great tomato for me so i've never
grown cherokee purple in any of the
manners
where they haven't tasted absolutely
wonderful so i think
i i do think nutrients soil etc
can and season
etc can
can induce
minor differences in performance of
tomatoes flavor-wise
but i i've found in my experience i've
grown four thousand different varieties
and
i've found a mediocre tomato is pretty
mediocre no matter where and how i've
grown it a superb tomato is pretty much
superb so i think the genes tend to
dominate
but pressures and other things can come
in and modify that a little bit um
straw bale gardening so i put two plants
in a strawberry which is equivalent of
220 gallon containers and my average
yield for plant has been 20 to 30 pounds
uh last year
it was in the 40 pound range so it blew
me away
um
but you i mean you're turning your straw
bales into essentially a wonderful
compost pile and you're regularly
watering it and feeding it
you're not dealing with clay
you're not dealing with a bed that may
have fusarium built up into it or
nematodes
so for me gardening in north carolina
containers and straw bales have been my
savior because at least i can get a
little bit of a head start on diseases i
mean septoria and early blight of course
come in eventually
but i can get some of the more difficult
to grow heirlooms to grow really well in
straw bales
yeah i think we are running all the time
thank you again greg it's a wonderful
talk
good i hope it met your needs uh but it
was great fun and i appreciate the
invitation everybody have a wonderful
career
for your breeding project
okay thank you
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu